you've really put climate change climate
transition financing at the heart of
your presidency what's your hope and
biggest expectations for cup 28.
cup 28 is a decisive moment and my
expectations and my hope is that we are
going to be successful in three Fields
first ambition
second targets and the third is finance
what ambition is concerned we need more
ambition we know that at the moment
being we are off track
but we can still make it to keep the 1.5
degree celsius warming limited to that
point and therefore we need to increase
our ambition the ambition of the
nationally determined contributions of
the different countries at the cop 28
but also for example to Peak greenhouse
gas emissions in 25.
so or for example to be very clear on
getting rid of unabated fossil fuels
these are topics that are very important
the second is targets it was Mike
Bloomberg said it only what gets
measured gets done and we do not have at
the moment being a global Target
how we how we want to deploy renewable
energy till 2030.
and we need such a global Target because
really we have to be on the right
trajectory therefore I hope we're going
to have a global Target defined that we
triple the deployment of renewable
energy till 2030 and that we double
Energy Efficiency doubling Energy
Efficiency means energy we do not use
and the third topic is climate Finance
so ambition targets finance and
president do you see that resolve from
world leaders who actually come together
and get more done in those three fields
um yes of course I mean it's still a
time in the run-up to the cop 28 where
we have to negotiate intensively but a
typical topic is for example climate
Finance as you know there is the promise
out there since years now that the
highly industrialized countries deliver
100 billion euros dollars sorry 100
billion dollars every year
two developing countries and emerging
economies
I'm deeply convinced that this year
we're going to make it and we're going
to deliver the European Union is
contributing its fair share with 27
billion dollars
so I hope that the other step too and
this is a matter of trust if we deliver
the developing countries uh trust the
whole process and then we can move
forward with the ambition for example
and the scale of this is immense right
how much of this money is actually
needed for emerging economies what's the
one thing that could hold them back
well um on one hand you need for the
emerging economies public investment
from us but you also need to attract
private Capital it won't work without
private capital and there we have a new
initiative because we've seen one of the
most effective tools
to nudge private Capital into green
projects sustainable projects are green
bonds
the European Union has the largest green
bond market
the greenbourne market otherwise is
dominated by the United States and China
but not there there are no developing
countries or low and middle income
countries that have sufficient green
Bond markets so we've decided we're
going to share our expertise with long
middle income countries so that they can
build up their green Bond markets and
we're going to be an anchor investor
that's very important
uh providing around about a billion to
leverage up to 15 to 20 billion because
we have to de-risk for the private
Capital the investment that are doing
so the green Bond markets one of the
major projects we're launching right now
and I put a lot of Hope in it that it
will attract the necessary Capital
private Capital to the Low Middle income
countries is there anything else that
actually Europe can offer in terms of
attracting this private Capital to
emerging economies yes there's a second
uh big topic that we have we call it
global gateway yeah global gateway is
our investment program
for critical infrastructure abroad and
of course a big chunk goes into green
projects sustainable projects and here
together with the private Capital that
we are leveraging it's around 300
billion euros that are ready to be
invested and here it's very fascinating
because I mean if we want to master the
the clean transition to renewable
energies we need the global South the
global South has all the resources in
abundance the wind and the Sun but it
doesn't have the infrastructure so it's
a perfect match if global gateway is
there our task is with global gateway to
de-risk private Capital here to to
create for example a conducive
judicial environment or regulatory
environment for projects that are going
forward I give you examples we have our
green hydrogen projects with Kenya and
with Namibia started but also with India
with Chile for example or we have
projects on Forest management with
Brazil
with Zambia with Indonesia we have a lot
of projects for solar and wind so all
critical infrastructure it's a win-win
situation we need this additional
renewable energy for example I was just
talking about the targets till 2030 a
tripling of deployment of renewable
energy and here for the private Capital
that really wants to go into these
projects we are de-risking and we're the
ones also who are showing this is true
and trusted as a project president the
global South is worried that actually
the cost of capital is so much higher
for them do you share the same concerns
the cost of capital is higher if for
example if we look at wind onshore it's
3.3 percent in the European Union it's
around 7.2 percent in Africa if you look
at Sun solar it's around four percent in
the European Union eight percent in
Africa so this is where global gateway
is absolutely the right instrument to go
in there de-risk be the anchor investor
make sure that the project functions and
attract a private Capital to these
projects present going back to you know
some of the green Bond markets that some
of these economies can develop
themselves what's the hardest thing
about that apart from attracting capital
is there any advice that you would do
well yes it is I mean you start from
scratch it's lots of technicalities it's
very technical so
um to share this expertise we built up
our green bond market so to share
everything which is necessary for of
course to invest also at the beginning
that this green bond market can be built
up
um and uh then get supply and demand at
the same time started this is why we are
so important as anchor investor is there
where do you see first so how much and
how quickly can that scale up you think
depends on the speed that we are
developing but we've seen in our own
green bond market it was a steep rise
immediately of the demand is out there
there's a lot of capital out there that
is looking for the good projects so
we've seen it with the own green bond
market it really went like this
oversubscribed enormously
um therefore the the idea was born to do
the same for the low and middle income
countries and as I said the the
resources they have they have them in
abundance they need the infrastructure
and therefore there's a lot of good
Capital out there that is looking for
the reliable projects therefore it's a
perfect match you've been president very
vocal on carbon pricing yeah why that's
a third Point
um we're at Carbon pricing
um in the European Union we have made a
very good experience with the topic of
carbon pricing what is the principle
it is a price on carbon so we say you
want to pollute you pay a price on the
carbon you're emitting you want to avoid
it the best thing is innovate into a
clean technology and that was that's
what happened in the European Union
I give you a few figures we introduced
carbon pricing in the industry in 2005.
since then the economy has grown by 65
percent
while the greenhouse gas emissions have
decreased in the uh the sectors that
were covered by carbon pricing by 35 so
an increase of growth in the economy a
decrease in greenhouse gas emissions and
we got
152 billion in revenues
from the carbon price which we could
immediately reinvest in the green
transition
so it's an extremely effective and
efficient tool it's Market driven it's
not just
um the the
entrepreneurs into Innovation couldn't
be better now if you look at the global
overall scenery only 23 percent of
greenhouse gas emissions are covered by
carbon pricing
so just imagine if we were able to
increase that to 60 percent
the amount of revenues that would come
back besides the fact that it cuts
greenhouse gases and grows Innovation
the amount of revenues we could get back
if we agree to give a big chunk of that
to the low and middle income countries
this is fresh money that has this triple
effect Innovation cutting greenhouse gas
emissions and investment capital in
prison on that were you surprised at the
speed at which this was adopted or
actually the scale of Revenue
I said at the beginning we covered
industry Now by now we just started to
cover road traffic and buildings
um so almost the whole economy is
covered by carbon pricing
we've made our initial learning
experience so we we know how to move
forward and interestingly
there's a lot of demand out there for
example China is building a carbon
pricing system we call it a mission
trading system
and they ask us for advice how can we do
that this is good news because of course
big emitters like China for example if
they start with that this is absolutely
the right way to go
and we have different regions in the
world where we have the carbon pricing
already but as I said only 23 of the
overall
CO2 emissions are covered so we need
much more is there a role for carbon
credits
yes absolutely yes carbon credits
have the advantage that if companies
want to invest in green or sustainable
products it is possible through carbon
credits what is important is and we
could do this as at cop28 that we
develop a framework that defines what is
a trusted carbon credit
so and this is necessary but it's doable
and I think it's also a perfect
instrument for voluntary investment for
example in sustainable projects
president what's the question you get
the most by investors that want to put
Capital to work but are either worried
about green washing yeah it's important
is very important is that in politics
we're very clear with the direction of
travel
it made a huge difference when I
introduced in 2019 the European green
deal with the climate law where all 27
member states of the European union
accepted and agreed that we have the
climate law with uh 20 by 2030 and by
2050 goals
because this gave predictability and
certainty through the private sector and
the business Community last week I
baptized the first container ship with
green methanol and the ship owner told
me that when he started to think about
planning such a containership with green
methanol uh it was a bad business case
but he wanted to contribute to something
good so he wanted to do this Innovative
stuff
and then we came with a European green
deal and with the climate law
and from then on he said immediately it
flipped into a
Frontline project a first mover
Advantage for him and this taught me
again it's so important that politics is
very clear
with the laws that we give or the
Frameworks that we give this is the
direction of travel so that there's
trust in the business Community they can
rely on what the direction of travel
that we are choosing together and the
investment then is there president do
you ever doubt when there's a country
that either you know is less ambitious
on that zero or wobbles with their
commitment do you ever doubt that the
transition will take longer than you
thought six months ago well
um at the moment being if we look at the
world
um or we're speaking about Europe
and the world okay now if you look at
the world we are off track without any
question but I'm deeply convinced and
I'm confident that we can we can
accelerate and we can be better
um so it's just a question of you know
that we join forces and that we move on
rapidly and uh I heard the introductory
remarks of Mike he was describing
rightly so
um the effects of climate change that we
are already feeling
so it's very clear that we have to work
against it and we can do it we can do it
through Innovation there are a lot of
good examples what we've done already
and where we have to go to
we have to convince the countries of
course those who are hesitant let's put
it that way what is important
I think we have been able to prove in
the European Union that the transition
to a circular clean economy is our new
growth strategy
and the United States did the same with
inflation reduction act for example so a
very clear message
the Next Generation
of advanced products are the clean
Technologies is clean energy for example
and the race is on now the whole world
is engaging and the question is who's
going to be the first who is going to be
the front line uh countries or developer
who's going to be the first mover and of
course we want to be it but competition
is always good so it shows that you can
grow you can be successful you can be
prosperous while cutting emissions while
transforming into a green economy and
circular economy president Wonderland
thank you so much for your time today
thank you thank you